all right buckle up welcome to Hannity
tonight a major win for the United
States the president's tough
negotiations with Mexico oh they paid
off in a massive big way president wins
Mexico agreed to stem the flow of
migration with tough new border policies
and 6,000 National Guard's troops and
President Trump yeah he had Mexico
buckle to their knees and without the
help of many Republicans and the
mainstream media oh what happens we're
gonna have a trade war okay the
president won the president stood strong
and we are better off for it we'll have
more in a moment but we start tonight
breaking just minutes ago big news from
the office of the Department of Justice
of the United States in a letter
obtained now by Fox News the assistant
attorney general Stephen Boyd explains
that John dorms investigation into the
origins of this Russia witch-hunt is
quote broad in scope and we'll cover
quote activities of US and foreign
intelligence services as well as
nongovernmental organizations and
individuals this is significant
confirmation that our mission to
investigate the investigators is not and
has never been in vain facts truth
justice as we've been telling you about
to cascade down on all of these deep
state bad actors those that abused power
we'll have a lot more in the course of
this hour and more in a moment but while
we focus on holding the government
accountable on Capitol Hill well you've
got Jerry Nadler circus and clown show
is in full gear and today the Democratic
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee literally jumped the shark
instead of passing laws or performing
responsible oversight Nadler instead
well he invited it to felon the known
purge or a liar John Dean to testify
that's right the John Dean the convicted
felon turned partisan hack turned fake
News CNN conspiracy theorist he was the
big star witness today but you might
remember John Dean was once the White
House Counsel on the Richard Nixon where
he was known as the master manipulator
of the Watergate cover-up he was accused
of lying a whopping 19 times to federal
prosecutors I think he forgot that there
were tapes and of course obstructing
justice John degan is
convicted felon he was disbarred many
decades ago for quote being guilty of
unethical unprofessional and unwarranted
conduct Oh disbarred - perfect guy for
fake - CNN liar big news anyway now the
felon rakes in a lot of cash trashing
Donald Trump daily for the mainstream
lying media mob and because of a CD
track record and penchant for lying
while he fits right in there
so naturally of course Jerry Nadler was
more than happy to give this known liar
convicted felon
yet another platform let's take a look
at the circus the last time I appeared
before your committee was July 11 1974
during the impeachment inquiry of
Richard Nixon in many ways the Mulla
report is to President Trump what the so
called Watergate roadmap officially
titled the grand jury report and
recommendation concerning transmission
of evidence to the House of
Representatives was to President Richard
Nixon state a little differently Special
Counsel Muller has provided this
committee with a roadmap convicted felon
or liar comparing a Republican president
to Richard Nixon by the way this is how
he now makes a living it's nothing new
for the disgraced CNN fake news
mouthpiece in fact a few years ago dean
wrote a book calling for the impeachment
of oh george w bush and that book was
entitled worse than Watergate this is
like a light he uses over and over again
and gets paid for doing the same thing
well before Dean was getting paid by CNN
to trash Donald Trump well he was doing
the exact same thing to former President
Bush he's a broken record play the loop
take a look I have really never seen as
secret of presidency as we now have I
think they found an old playbook down in
the basement that belonged to Richard
Nixon and they said well this stuff
looks like it works be specific with me
what is worse than Watergate if there's
anything that really it is the bottom
line it's taking the nation to war in a
time when they might not have had to go
to war and people dying I wouldn't use
the tie
worse than Watergate if I didn't truly
believe that what's happening in this
presidency is far worse than anything
that did happen during the Nixon
presidency worse the Watergate worse
than Watergate worse the Watergate it
gets paid for regurgitated the same
stupid line over and over again as they
convicted felon and this is a known liar
and John Dean has been used as a prop by
the mainstream media mob and the
Democratic Party for years today's
hearing was a sham a circus Democratic
propaganda paid for by you the American
people earlier Congressman Matt Gaetz he
had this to say that neither star
witness pretty big takedown let's take a
look do you have personal knowledge
regarding the truth or falsity of a
single material fact in the Moller
report I think if you recall the first
thing I said I'm not here as a fact
witness and throughout history you
accuse presidents of acting like Richard
Nixon and you make money off of it right
not all presidents here we sit today in
this hearing with the ghost of Christmas
past because the chairman of the
committee has gone to the Speaker of the
House and sought permission to open an
impeachment inquiry but she has said no
you are functionally here as a prop
because they can't impeach President
Trump because 70% of Democrats want
something that 60% of Americans don't
checkmate and congressman Gates was just
one of many Republicans who called out
Dean and it's so self-serving abusively
biased testimony that I mentioned he was
a felon and he obstructed justice take a
look the corrupt cabal what we see of
struck Paige McCabe call me and others
how we actually got started here I
believe that they have the Godfather
here today mr. Dean now we got John Dean
45 years ago went to pled guilty to
obstruction of justice
and now coming in to enlighten the
Judiciary Committee on obstruction of
justice when we could be going right to
the start of how this whole thing
started we're not just talking about
your credibility is witness your a
biased witness as well you spent the
last 45 years trying to rehabilitate
yourself and I don't blame you and
you've written numerous books you've
you've claimed multiple Republican
administrations as being worse
in Watergate now mr. Dean I have no
problem with you having an opinion you
paid your debt to society and you've
made your opinion clear in the last two
years did you know you've sent 970
tweets about Donald Trump all 970 tweets
about Donald Trump are anti Donald Trump
did I happen to mention that John Dean
was a liar obstructed justice and that
he's a felon and his testimonies today
just smacks a democratic desperation
House Democrats want to impeach
President Trump over a hoax no collusion
no conspiracy no obstruction he's not a
fact witness the special counsel
recommended no charges the Attorney
General Deputy Attorney General Office a
legal counsel presented no indictments
and it had nothing to do with Department
of Justice policy or any constitutional
issue as oh even Muller said compare
that to the Independent Counsel Ken
Starr who will join us in a moment well
following his 1998 investigation into
them President Bill Clinton well Ken
Starr detailed 11 specific felonies real
crimes for which Clinton could be
impeached Clinton lost his law license
and later in fact was impeached but get
this back then Jerry Nadler and his
fellow Democrats they pushed hard they
didn't want the Starr report released to
the public
wow what a different Jerry Nadler he was
back in the day let's take a look the
staff of the Judiciary Committee perhaps
the the Chairman and ranking minority
members of the Judiciary Committee is
going to have to go over this material
at least the 4 or 500 pages in the
report to determine what is fit for
release and what is as a matter of
decency and protecting people's privacy
rights people who may be totally
innocent third parties what must not be
released at all and also its Nadler
circus no shame nothing but a political
hack wasting your money and what has to
be one of becoming now one of the most
epic flip flops in American political
history only a few weeks ago Nadler is
actually threatening the Attorney
General of the United States Attorney
General bar with contempt of Congress
well not for declassifying just to full
and seven partial lines of the Muller
report everything else was released on
obstruction well the section that was
redacted
because the law demands it it had Grand
Jury material he was asking the Attorney
General to commit a crime and reveal
grand jury material he literally wanted
America's top law enforcement official
to break the law or hold him in contempt
this from a guy who desperately tried to
keep the star report hidden from you we
the American people without a doubt that
is hypocrisy on steroids and human
growth hormone congressman Nadler is now
reportedly putting his contempt plans on
hold jiwoo gee I wonder how long this is
going to last but the Trump
administration they're done they're not
going to participate in his political
circus which is the right decision why
for years the White House cooperated
fully with multiple investigations we
had the FBI nine-month investigation no
collusion House Intel committee
investigation no collusion by partisan
probe in the Senate no collusion
Mulder's 22 month witch-hunt no
collusion no obstruction and during the
years long process not one time not a
single moment that the Trump White has
ever exert executive privilege they
didn't assert at once the president
encouraged every person in the White
House in his administration to
participate fully and they did they
handed over 1.5 million documents to the
Special Counsel and the White House
attorney even Don Magan was interviewed
by Muller for 30 hours which to me is
insanity the president answered Muller's
questions himself now it's all over
there was no collusion and the president
will not allow Democrats to literally
drag Americans through this process yet
again well what would be a fifth
investigation and that's why the
president is now rightly saying enough
s'en of asserting executive privilege
House Democrats they are not going to
have the ability to relitigate the
Russia probe for a fifth time it's now
abuse of power and outright harassment
of a duly elected president more
importantly all the people that work for
the president trying to serve their
country should not again have to shell
out tens and tens of thousands of
dollars in new legal fees answering the
same questions over and over and over
again and literally sit for a perjury
trap witnesses and documents forget it
it's done that will
not be made available this is the right
decision from the president the vast
powers of our government should never be
used to oppress Americans and harass a
sitting president and cost the American
taxpayers what is now a fifth
investigation into the same topic and by
the way President Trump is not the first
president to invoke executive privilege
although he did not do it with Muller
former President Clinton did it a
whopping 14 times and meanwhile Obama
successfully utilized executive
privilege blocking the requests of
documents surrounding remember fast and
furious the gun-running scandal well in
American actually died as a result of
that stupid policy and of course the
horrific fast and furious program Obama
also tried to withhold documents
surrounding the failed Solyndra project
and even Benghazi and the attack there
ultimately he tried but he turned him
over he was forced to I have some advice
for Nadler ship and all the radical
extreme Democrats that are weaponizing
and abusing their power in their
committees against the President of the
United States the American people are
smart they're not going to support your
impeachment and by the way they're sick
and tired of your lies your conspiracy
theories and your phony Russia hoax if
you continue down this road which I
highly encourage you to do well
you'll pay at the ballot box and you'll
guarantee a Trump landslide in 2020